[Applause]
[Music]
many of you
have written to us asking for a video
about what's going on in turkey and
believe me
the situation there is quite dangerous
and in case you were wondering
no this time donald trump is not to
blame for this in fact the u.s sanctions
are just the tip of the iceberg here and
this is an iceberg that could wreck
many ships and when we say ships we
really mean european banks
just look at the map we're showing here
[Music]
turkey is a bridge between europe and
asia we're talking about a country with
a population
as big as germany a country where europe
has been
investing for decades companies
factories and of course there are lots
and lots of loans want an example well
here you are have you ever heard
of bbva it's the second biggest bank in
spain well turkey is the third biggest
market
for this bank in other words when the
turks sneeze a lot of europeans
end up with a cold aren't scared enough
yet well
listen up turkey is an important nato
member
after america they have the biggest army
in the alliance and they are one of the
few countries with a muslim majority
and secular constitution at least for
now yep you heard that right
we said so far the truth is that the
turkish president
erdogan well he is not a big fan of
secularism
erdogan is something like the anakin
skywalker of politics he started out as
the good guy in the movie
but we all know that eventually he will
fall to the dark side
in this case the dark side is a mix
between religious fanaticism
and well good old populism erdogan likes
to portray himself as the defender of
the average man those turks that live in
rural areas like
kanye completely outside of the glamour
of istanbul the turks there they don't
have amazing salaries and they maintain
a traditional lifestyle and well
who do these people need to be protected
against well of course that would be
the western conspiracy that wants to end
turkey
this explains why news like this is so
important for erdogan's narrative
u.s imposes sanctions on turkish
officials over detained
american pastor nonetheless this is just
the
tip of the iceberg first of all the
actual reason behind the u.s sanctions
is
not the pastor but the military and
sanctions with
the kurds in syria but that's another
story for another video the truth is
turkey's crisis has been going on
for three years already and this isn't
just a political crisis
in fact the biggest problem is economics
we're talking about a small scale
venezuela here
right at the very gates of europe but
now the question is
what is going on in turkey what happened
in this country to cause them
to fall to the dark side of economics
and importantly
do we really have to be scared today
we're going to answer all of these
questions but before we do as always
let's take a look back at the history
[Music]
erdogan the savior turkey is famous for
merry things
saint sophia kebabs and inflation
[Music]
since 1970 and until the year 2000
turkey had
sky-high inflation rates many years they
even surpassed the 100 mark
this means that from one year to the
next prices
would double and what happens when you
have so much inflation and you live
so close to wealthy european countries
well
you become a cheap labor disneyland
companies like renault of peugeot built
lots of factories in turkey but hold on
a second because i can guess
what you're probably thinking right now
you're probably thinking well okay simon
but
isn't this actually good news for a
country well yes
and no at the same time for example in
the 1960s renault opened a factory in
bursa a city in northern turkey
manufacturing cars in bursa is very
cheap for renault since the turkish lira
was devaluing year after year renault
had to pay
lower and lower salaries
nonetheless when they got the money from
selling those cars do you really think
they kept it inside turkey
of course not if turkish money was
losing value so fast the smartest thing
you could do with your money was take it
out of the country as fast as you
possibly could
this is why turkey seemed doomed to
stagnation
that was until the year 2003 that's the
year erdogan came to power
[Music]
his main goal was to keep inflation
below 10
he created a new currency the turkish
lira this was a currency
far more stable than the previous one
[Music]
[Applause]
and as soon as inflation was in hand the
turkish economy it made
a 180 degree shift all of a sudden many
european companies started
investing in turkey this included banks
one of them the spanish bbba we
mentioned previously invested
in this country big time in fact so much
so that now turkey
is their third largest market so in the
2000s turkey
it was in fashion rule of law and
monetary stability meant that companies
could
reinvest in the country so in less than
10 years your average turkish worker
went from making 800 us dollars a month
to making more than one thousand two
hundred dollars a month
but not only that in those first erdogan
years new industries like
tourism developed turkey went from 13
million tourists
to 39 million and what about turkish
companies
well have you ever heard of turkish
airlines in the 90s turkish airlines was
just another carrier but since they
could now reinvest their profit they
ended up becoming an
aviation juggernaut and believe me
this is not an isolated case if there's
one great example of the turkish mineral
it has to be yielded's holdings this
company started out as a family-owned
bakery and now they've
already bought european brands like
godiva chocolates or
united biscuits today yielders holdings
is the world's
third biggest company in the entire food
sector
so in other words the turkish economy it
was absolutely
on fire
[Music]
and since the economy was on fire no one
really seemed to care that erdogan had
been to prison
for being a part of a radical group at
the end of the day the country was still
democratic and erdogan
was the arab rock star he was the chosen
one he was the one who was going to
bring the islamic world
to the bright side back then turkey
wanted to be
european they were just about to become
a member of the european union
as a fun fact in 2003 they even won the
eurovision song contest
[Music]
[Applause]
but as you might know the negotiations
to become
a part of the eu extended over a really
long time so what happens
well erdogan lost his patience and he
essentially said oh what so i'm not cool
enough to join your club well you know
what
i'm tired of being western i'm tired of
a separation of powers i'm tired of
secularism
all of that it's now over now is the
time
for the new erdogan
in the last five years things started to
sour for erdogan first he was personally
involved in many corruption cases but
worst of all was news like this
istanbul ataturk airport attack 41 dead
and more than 230 hurt daesh attacks
have brought islamic terrorism
and insecurity to the streets of turkey
and the damage to the tourism industry
was immediate in just two years tourism
income has fallen
by 25 percent and this is especially
worrying given that tourism accounts for
13 percent of the turkish economy but
that's not all foreign investment
has fallen by half and now you might be
wondering
well why well there are two reasons for
this
the first one is the lack of a chance
that turkey is going to become a part of
the european union
and the second one well that's erdogan
himself yes
dear viewer islamic radicalism is not
just a danger politics-wise it is also
a danger for economics
turkey's erdogan calls interest rates
the mother of
all evil the lira slides according to
erdogan the so-called economic orthodoxy
is a
western invention that will destabilize
turkey this borrowing money with
interesting it goes against islam so he
went to the central bank
and forced them to lower the interest
rates and start printing money and what
if the central banker will refuse and he
said i just
i just don't want to do that well these
are erdogan's words
a central bank can't take this
independence and set aside the signals
given by the president
erdogan speaking to bloomberg so in
other words after the failed coup d'etat
of 2016 erdogan has finally
fallen to the dark side
he thinks he can manage the economy at
his will and every
rational critic against his economic
policy is seen
as a western conspirator he even named
his son-in-law as the finance minister
this new economic paradigm is not a free
market or social democracy
this is the new erdoganomics
do you need money to pay for your
spending well you simply print it
are turkish companies complaining flood
the market with cheap credit
in less than two years turkish banks
have given more than 50 billion
worth of loans and all of this is with
almost no interest
the result well that's a crazy
devaluation of the turkish lira in 2014
the exchange rate between the us dollar
and the turkish lira
was about 2.5 euros to the dollar at the
time of the making of this video however
the exchange rate is more than
six liras to the dollar this means that
the turkish lira has lost two-thirds of
its value compared to four years ago
this also partially accounts for why
inflation rates have risen so high
to 11.9 percent in the end of 2017.
all right all right now what are you
thinking 11.9 doesn't sound so bad i
mean in argentina they have three times
that inflation the truth is that you
need some time between a devaluation
and the rise in day-to-day prices so who
were the first ones
suffering the effects of this deflation
well those would be the companies that
had loans
in foreign bank and there are more than
a few of them remember yields holdings
the food industry beer moth
well here you go check this out
[Music]
turkish owner of godiva chocolate to
restructure 6.5 billion
worth of debt estimations say that
foreign debt from turkish companies
surpasses 300 billion dollars for a
better understanding this is the same
amount of money spent in all of the
bailouts of greece
and meanwhile the inflation rate is
starting to grow
little by little this year 2018 it's
already reached 15
and all the non-governmental estimations
say that at the beginning of 2019
it's going to rise to 22 percent
[Applause]
turkey's sovereign credit rating cut
deeper into junk as
snp sees recession next year add to this
the sanctions imposed by donald trump
we're going to talk about the
reasons behind the sanctions in another
video but here we want to focus
on the economics because in the middle
of all of this there is another player
with a lot to lose
and that's the european union
banks like the spanish bbva and the
french bnp of parabas or the
italian unicredit have lent more than
190 billion
to turkish companies so far bbva has
already lost
half of the value of those investments
so you can already
imagine the big gap that a turkish
collapse would leave
so far erdogan has said that he won't
ask for a bailout from the international
monetary fund and he will not
raise capital controls either but can he
really
stick to his words we just don't know
here all we know is that both qatar and
china have already promised to help the
turkish economy but
it is still too soon to tell what's
going to happen
so now the question will it goes to you
do you think turkey will become
the european venezuela could this
localized crisis create a bigger crisis
all across europe could erdogan pull
everybody
to the dark side
well please leave your answer in the
comments section below and as always
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine and remember
that we publish brand new videos every
week so
do hit that subscribe button so you
won't miss out on a post and if you like
this video give us a thumbs up
and as always i'll see you next time and
if you want to learn more about politics
and hear more of my lovely voice
don't forget to check out the reconsider
podcast at reconsider media.com
reconsider is a podcast that challenges
you to reconsider your views by
providing context but we don't do the
thinking
for you